foreign
welcome to the simply learn YouTube
channel in today's video we are going to
talk about how to increase your
website's traffic which is a very
important aspect of using a website to
grow your business or grow your brand
so we will talk about why this is
important to increase your website
traffic what are the techniques you can
use to achieve this what are the
benefits of doing it and as a bonus I
will share with you some tools and some
example websites yeah that will give you
a good idea of how they increase their
website so let's get on to this but
before I am our campman I am your
digital navigator for this video and if
you liked the video hit the Subscribe
button yeah so you can join our Channel
and
um if you like the video you can also
click the like the like button so are
you ready let's get started let me give
you to start with some interesting stats
about websites as of 2021 there are an
estimated
1.7 billion websites on the internet now
the number of active websites though is
likely to be significantly lower but the
exact number of websites is constantly
changing as websites are being developed
every day and others are taking down now
the majority of the websites are hosted
on servers located in the United States
he had the top five most popular website
categories are business and industry art
and entertainment computers and internet
science and health and you know what the
most popular website in is in the world
well there's no surprise there it is
Google closely followed by YouTube and
number three Facebook now did you know
that the number of active websites is
the largest in the world in China
followed by the United States and Japan
there are over
4.9 billion web pages indexed by Google
to give you the best search results on
the Google search engine result paste
there are lots of domains being used
here now did you know the most popular
domain is the.com domain followed by
dotnet and Dot org
and to close this list of impressive
statistics that WordPress is the most
popular content management system used
to build websites over 60 percent of the
top 10 million websites use web use
WordPress to develop and to um to manage
their website and finally the average
website receives about 200 to 300 visits
a day
so now these numbers tell you that
websites of course are a key channel for
you to generate sales and to generate
awareness for your business so let's
have a look then how you can grow your
traffic on your website and how you can
generate more sales and higher awareness
for your business
here are some of the reasons why
businesses use your website they use it
for increased visibility for
cost-effective marketing for improved
customer service for increased sales and
for competitive advantage
yes so if you talk about increased face
visibility a website allows you to reach
a global audience which is very
important these days because there is
internet connections around the world
which means you can increase your
awareness and thereby you can increase
your sales
a website is also very effective and
very cost effective to Market your
business because it can be updated it
can be updated easily it can be updated
quickly and it can be used to reach a
wide audience at a relatively low cost
compared to printing a brochure or doing
an advertisement
a website can provide your customers
with information about your products
about your business about your services
as well as how to contact your business
this can improve your customer service
and increase the satisfaction of your
customers
now many websites are being used as
e-commerce platforms yes so you can sell
your products and services online so a
lot of businesses they use their website
to sell actually and create a new sales
and revenue Channel
and finally yeah you they use the
website to create a competitive
Advantage having a professional
good-looking well-designed website can
give your business a competitive
advantage over your competitors and
um if those competitors do not have a
website yeah it can help
establish credibility and trust with
potential customers so you will get many
benefits in having a website so let's
take a look at some of those benefits
first your website can be used to
Showcase your products and provide
detailed information including images
descriptions and pricing of your
products and of course that can help
your potential customers to make
well-informed purchasing decisions
you can set up an online store allowing
customers to purchase products directly
through your website thereby increasing
your sales and your Revenue
you can allow your customers to leave a
review and rating for your products
which can help you to build trust and
credibility with future clients who want
to buy your products
there's so much promotion to you that
you can do on your website and you can
link your website with your social media
so you can allow your prayer your
customers to promote and to share your
products from your websites with their
friends and with their followers again
another way to encourage reach and
visibility
you can help gather information about
your customers so you can use that data
to add to Target specific audiences you
can look at your website yeah sure you
can look at your competitors how are
they promoting their products on their
website yeah so a really good example of
a website that promotes products
extremely well is Amazon yeah so let's
have a look at the Amazon website Amazon
is an e-commerce platform that sells a
wide variety of products like books
Electronics clothing the website
features detailed product information as
you can see it features customer reviews
and it's a convenient online shopping
cart system
now Amazon also offers a whole range of
additional services like hosting like
Prime music video
Etc Amazon has really reinvented the
High Street yeah so it's called the
Amazon effect and those businesses that
are not able to change and um and and go
online and and look into those new
online opportunities they may miss the
boat because the Amazon machined Amazon
train continues to ride and it's getting
bigger and bigger so a good way of using
your website is to promote to you for
for promoting of your products so the
next reason why you need to increase
your website is that it can help you
increase awareness
yeah there are many benefits to you
seeing a website to increase awareness
for your products your service or your
brand you can reach a global audience so
you can make it a very effective way to
increase awareness for your brands or
products wherever your customers are in
the world and a website can be
relatively low-cost way to reach that
Global audience especially compared to
traditional forms of advertising such as
print or broadcasting it's easy to track
the success of a website-based awareness
campaign using analytics tools such as
Google analytics which can help you
understand why your audience yeah and
why they access your website and they
you can track the effectiveness of your
marketing efforts and your Market
data-driven decisions
so not a benefit that you can get for
this awareness is that your website can
be easily updated with fresh new content
and promotions making it easy to adapt
your marketing efforts to changing
circumstances in the markets so you can
really help you in establishing your
brand and create a consistent image and
message across all of your marketing
efforts
you can then use your website to
generate leads for your business by
capturing contact information from
visitors and follow and following up
with them through an email marketing or
other ways of connecting with them so a
well-designed and well-maintained
website can help to establish your
business as a credible and trustworthy
source of information which can help to
increase awareness and Trust among your
potential customers
now a good example of a website that
excels in creating awareness is ted.com
yeah that is a non-profit organization
that aims to spread an example of a
website that excels in increasing
awareness through its website is tet.com
Ted is a non-profit organization that
aims to spread ideas through powerful
talks yeah their website features a wide
range of talks on various topics such as
science technology business and culture
the website as you can see is designed
to be user friendly and easy to navigate
with a clean and simple layout now why
do they excel in Awareness first of all
because high quality engaging content
that they feature on their website yes
so the the TED Talks feature on the
website they are carefully curated and
features some of the most inspiring and
thought-provoking ideas from experts in
the various fields they also have a
strong social media presence
yeah Ted uses social media platforms
like Twitter Instagram and YouTube to
promote it content and engage with an
audience they have also got a very
strong search engine optimization yeah
the website is optimized for search
engines making it easy for people to
find Ted Talks on the topics that are
interested to them and the website is
easy to share it's very easy for
visitors to share Tech talks on social
media and on other platforms which help
them increase the reach of their talks
and thereby increase the awareness of
the Tet brands
finally the Tet brand has very
consistent branding yeah it features a
consistent brand and a consistent design
which helps building tet as a trusted
and credible source
so as a result ted.com I believe is a
great example of a website that excels
in increasing awareness through its
website and it has become one of the
most popular and well respected websites
in the world
good let's move on here
yes so the next is that
um building your website traffic can
really help you in developing your SEO
ranking it gives you a higher ranking
for various reasons search engines use
website traffic as a signal of the
website's popularity and Authority yeah
if a website receives a lot of traffic
it is more likely to be a valuable and
authoritative resource for users which
can help improve the visibility in
search engine results
Now search engines also use a thing like
a click-through rate as a ranking Factor
if websites pages are appearing in
search engine results engines yeah and
in search engine results and they
receive a lot of clicks it is more
likely to be relevant and a valuable
resource for users which Google will
reward you with with a higher ranking so
that can improve your visibility in the
search engine results
service engines use also effect like
bound trade as a ranking Factor yeah so
a bound trade is when people are getting
on a website on a web page and they
don't browse to any other pages but they
leave from the same page that they
arrive on
so a high bound rate in general is not a
good sign yeah you want to get your
bound rate low so many people many
people they click to other Pages as well
so if a website's pages are appearing in
search engine results and users are
staying on the website and visiting
multiple Pages it's more likely that
they find relevant content which is
useful which is valuable which can help
them to improve its visibility in the
search engine results
so search engines also use a thing like
backlinks as a ranking Factor the more
backlinks your website is pointing to it
the more authoritative and valuable it
is considered by the search engines so
if a website receives a lot of traffic
it's more likely to be linked by other
websites which can then help improve
your visibility in the search engine
results
social media signals also play an
important role in the ranking yeah if a
website gets a lot of shares a lot of
likes and engagement on social media
that is considered popular and
authoritative by the search engines all
in all a website that receives a lot of
traffic is more likely to be considered
valuable and authoritative by search
engines which can then help improve the
visibility in the search engine results
by getting a lower ranking on the search
engine results please now one example of
a website that is really good in
increasing a web in increasing awareness
through SEO is Wikipedia
Wikipedia is an online encyclopedia that
contains over 6 million articles in
various languages now the website is a
prime example of how SEO can be used to
increase websites traffic and awareness
so they are doing this in several ways
first of all by showcasing high quality
informative content
yes so their articles are are written by
a community of volunteer editors and are
carefully reviewed for accuracy and
completeness this ensures that the
articles are of the highest quality
which makes them more likely to rank
well in search engine results
now their pages are optimized for search
engines yeah they include relevant
keywords in the titles and The Meta tags
and by creating internal links between
the various articles
Wikipedia has a very strong backlink
profile which means that many other
websites link to its articles for
reference of course this helps establish
Wikipedia as a trusted and authoritative
source of information and again the
search engines they like that and they
reward that in giving it a higher
ranking and then Wikipedia's content is
regularly updated yeah so it's
constantly updated with new articles new
information which helps to keep the
website fresh and relevant
and finally Wikipedia is mobile friendly
it is optimized for mobile devices so
their articles are easy to read when
you're on the go that helps improve the
user experience and of course Google
like the user experience is another
thing that search engines will consider
when they decide on the ranking for for
different web pages and websites so as a
result of these SEO efforts Wikipedia is
one of the most popular and well
respected websites in the world and it's
a prime example of how SEO can be used
to increase your website's awareness and
traffic
good so let's look at the next one which
is about conversion
conversion is very important for your
website traffic because it measures the
effectiveness of your website in
achieving your goals and your objectives
yeah if everybody visits your website
but nobody is actually clicking on the
calls to action on your website then it
is not doing it's not achieving the
objectives that you may have set out now
a conversion is a specific action that a
website visitor can take which is
considerable considered valuable to your
website to the website owner such as
making a purchase filling out a contact
form or signing up for a newsletter so
when a website is able to convert a high
percentage of its visitors it means that
the website is effective in
communicating the value proposition and
make it easy for visitors to take the
desired actions so why then are
conversions so important for website
traffic first a high conversion rate
means that more visitors take a desired
action which can lead to more sales for
going through your website
yeah a conversion is also important for
lead generation a high conversion rate
means that more visitors are providing
their contact information which can then
be used to generate leads and nurture
those leads with email marketing to for
them to become customers
a high conversion rate means that more
visitors are engaging with your content
and becoming aware of your brand which
can help in building trust and building
loyalty
and a high conversion rate means that
your website is optimized it is
effective in communicating the value
proposition and making it easy for
visitors to take the desired action
which could be used as a benchmark to
opt the website to optimize your website
even further and make it more more
effective
a high conversion rate also means that
you are effective that you are
successful in reaching your target
audience and you resonate with them so
it will help you in better understanding
your audience and make data different
decisions so overall conversion is a
very important metric for the success of
your website and had done properly it
can really help you in increasing your
website's traffic because it is shows
you that you're achieving your goals and
objectives and they can provide you with
valuable insights into the effectiveness
of your website the far designed content
and the marketing efforts
now here are two examples of websites
that are very effective in driving
conversions first of all is not this one
the first one is booking.com
yeah so booking.com is an online travel
agency that specializes in lodging and
reservations
are the websites user-friendly design
they're very clear call to actions and
easy to use booking process all
contribute to the high conversions they
experience on their website they also
offer a Rewards program for frequent
Travelers and that's a best price
guarantee which incentivizes user to
book through their website
zillow.com is another one
yeah they are a real estate website
they provide users with a wide range of
tools and resources to help them buy
sell or rent a property now the website
uses very friendly design
very clear calls to action an easy to
use property search and filtering tools
and these all contribute to a high
conversion
they also offer a wide range of services
so are like mortgage appraisal and Home
Improvement recommendations which makes
it a One-Stop shop for all your home
related needs which further enhances the
user experience and ultimately increases
conversions
so both of these websites Zillow and
booking have been designed to make the
process as easy and seamless as possible
for the user which helps it to increase
the conversions and drive website
traffic
the next benefit and the next reason why
you need to increase your website
traffic is that it can help you improve
trust by providing social proof
increasing brand awareness and showing
that your website is providing valuable
and useful information of products
your website can help you build that
trust in many ways yeah so when your
website receives a lot of traffic it can
be seen as a sign of popularity and
Authority
and if a lot of people are visiting your
website it can be issued that your
website is providing valuable and useful
information which can help to increase
that trust
seeing a high volume on your website can
act as a form of social proof which is
the idea that people are more likely to
trust something if they see others doing
it if your website is receiving a lot of
traffic it can be seen it should be
assumed that others trust your website
which can encourage others to trust you
more
yeah when your website receives a lot of
traffic it is more likely that visitors
are engaging with your content like
reading articles or watching videos or
leaving comments now this engagement
again can be a sign of your website's
credibility and Authority which can then
help in increase trust in your website
so a high volume of traffic can increase
brand awareness which can help to build
trust by making your brand more familiar
to users
a high volume of traffic can also result
in an increase of reviews and
testimonials which can help to build
your trust
positive reviews and testimonials can
help to improve your website's
reputation again which can lead to more
traffic and more Trust
and a website that receives a high
volume of traffic is likely to have
implemented measures to ensure the
security of the website and the data of
the users
yes so and again that can help build
trust among the users as well
one example of a website that drives
website traffic through positive
branding is Apple
apple.com is known for its iconic brand
and its high quality cutting-edge
products the website design as you can
see is clean
yeah it's minimalistic it's high quality
product photography and very clear
messaging and all help to convey the
Apple brand and its values of innovation
Simplicity and elegance
now Apple's website is also designed to
be very user friendly and very easy to
navigate making it easy for visitors to
find the product they are looking for
yeah the website also features a today
at Apple section which allows visitors
to find and register for workshops
events and creative sessions in Apple
stores around the world again that helps
to build a community around a brand and
enhances the user's experience
so Apple's website is a prime example of
how a well-designed and user-friendly
website with very good branding can help
Drive traffic through this positive
branding and build a community around it
now after all this information about why
you should focus on increasing your
website traffic let's look at how you
increase your website traffic
yeah we've now looked at why it's
important let's look at the how to do it
yeah so we should put this in the
context of the three different types of
digital marketing that businesses can
use to reach and engage with their
target audience
yeah it's owned paid and earned
so old digital marketing refers to the
digital marketing efforts that you own
and that you can control such as your
website yes such as your
um so it's your email list your social
media accounts this type of digital
marketing allows you to build a brand
and establish an online presence and it
gives you control over the message and
the audience
pay digital marketing refers to efforts
that you pay for such as online
advertise advertising pay-per-click
campaigns and sponsored content this
type of digital marketing allows you to
reach a larger and more targeted
audience and can be a very cost
effective way to drive traffic and
increase conversions
earned digital marketing refers to
efforts that are generated by your
customers such as Word of Mouth customer
reviews and social media shares it's
also where other people other magazines
online magazines are writing about you
like online PR This is highly effective
because it is based on the trust and
credibility that others have in your
business
so each type of digital marketing owned
paid and earned has its own strengths
and weaknesses and businesses should use
a combination of all three to achieve
their marketing goals
Digital model marketing can help you
build brand awareness establish an
online presence
pay digital marketing can help you to
reach a larger and more targeted
audience and earn digital marketing can
help you to build trust and credibility
yeah and all three together with the
optimum spot which you find in the
center is the perfect way to drive your
website traffic to grow your website
traffic so let's go into a bit more of
the details here yeah so the number one
way to increase your website traffic is
through search engine optimization
yeah SEO as it's called is the process
of optimizing your website to improve
the visibility and the ranking of your
website or web pages in search engine
results pages also called serps
by implementing SEO best practices you
can increase the likelihood that your
web pages will appear at the top of the
search engine results for Relevant
keywords and phrases which can then
drive more traffic to your website
so here are a few ways that you can use
SEO to increase traffic to your website
first of all by optimizing your
website's content structure and
Technical elements you can improve the
visibility in the search engine results
pages so more people will find your
website and therefore more people will
click it and therefore more people will
go to your website
long tail keywords that you can specify
are longer and more specific phrases
that are less competitive and more
targeted
by targeting those long tail keywords in
your SEO practices you can drive more
targeted traffic to your website
a very important part of your search
engine optimization are the meta tags on
your web pages such as the title tag and
The Meta description they provide search
engines with information about the
content of your website
and by optimizing these tags you can
make sure that your website appears more
relevant and attractive to search
engines and users
now we know yeah that search engines
favor websites that provides the highest
quality and relevant content so when you
create an update content regularly like
a blog or other types of content you
will attract more visitors to your
website because Google will feature your
fresh content in the search engine
results pages
backlinks are also very important yeah
they point from other websites to your
websites
search engines view these links as a
sign of your website's Authority and by
building these backlinks you can improve
your website's visibility in the search
engine result pages
so by implementing these SEO best
practices you can increase your
website's traffic by having a higher
presence in the search engine results
pages
the next way to increase your website's
traffic and we just referred to it in
the SEO section is create content
yeah this effect people use Google and
other search engines to D to discover
detailed and reliable responses to their
inquiries and your content has the
opportunity to feature among those
results so creating high quality
informative and keyword Rich content can
help your website rank higher in those
search and search engine results pages
and thereby more people see your pages
and thereby more people will click on
them
so sharing your content on social media
platforms and encourage people to share
them can of course help to increase that
reach and drive even more traffic to
your website so very also important that
you create content that which is
valuable and informative that other
websites will want to link to where you
get high quality backlinks and again
that will help you in your search engine
rankings so creating a blog post on your
website is probably the easiest way to
get started with good content on your
website
when you launch a black blog make sure
that you regularly post high quality
content yep and that your blog has very
good sections yeah that you you use the
um the the category section in your blog
to give people access to your the
history of your blog posts as well
websites with blog posts often have over
400 percent more pages scrolled by
search engines and those websites
without
now another interesting fact is that
sites that publish more than 16 articles
per month they attract roughly three and
a half times as many visitors as those
that publish only one to four pieces of
content among a month
another very important piece of content
that is highly regarded by the search
engines is video
yeah it's a great way for people to find
out what your business does and what
they do best
so here are some tips on how to use
video on your website and how it can
help you drive traffic to your website
make sure that you host your videos on a
platform like YouTube and then embed the
video on your website that can really
help drive more traffic to your website
create a landing page for your video it
will increase the chances of conversions
as the visitors will have a specific
call to action
maybe you could create a video sitemap
for your website it will help to search
engines to understand the structure of
your website and improve the visibility
of your videos
Google or YouTube automatically creates
transcriptions for your videos
now if you make sure that you
um you you proofread those
transcriptions and save them then Google
will actually index those transcriptions
so they can another way to help increase
your visibility of your videos and make
them accessible to a wider audience
make sure you add your video on your
home page integrate them in your blog
posts yep and it will make sure your
visitors stay on your website longer to
experienced video but don't forget the
key to increasing website traffic
through your videos is that they are
high quality and that they are very
valuable informative and engaging to
your audience
Nothing Stops you from updating old
content
yes so Google Dean does Google's
algorithm will also reward you when you
update existing or update old content
yeah so they want you to be the subject
matter experts in the topics that you
write about
so don't make don't Focus only on new
content but repurpose your old blog post
maybe repurpose them as an infographic
or an explanation video there are
several ways to update your old content
so first you can refresh the content
making sure that it is up to date and
accurate
you could add visuals to your old
content to incorporate images videos and
infographic to make them more engagement
you have to make them more engaging you
can optimize for SEO
yeah like adding the metadata you can
promote the content so you can share the
updated content on social media to drive
more traffic to your website you can
consider internal linking between your
updated content you can repurpose the
content so put it into another format
and don't forget to use Google analytics
to analyze which Pages perform well and
which Pages or contents do not perform
well
it goes without saying social media
marketing is a very powerful way to
increase your website traffic
each day the average person spends over
two hours on social media and business
is Now understand on how to capitalize
on those consumers and if they do
capitalize on the social engaged
customers they can use that to increase
brand awareness increase infinity and
loyalty and of course drive more traffic
to your website now the key to being on
social media and being successful on
social media as a business is to be
genuine
it's tempting to follow every Trend and
follow every fed but your scrollers see
right through this yeah they are not
impressed with that they want you to be
genuine so here are some suggestions to
get started share links to your website
and specific pages on your social media
profile
this will allow your followers to easily
access your website and the content you
want to promote and thereby it will
increase traffic
use relevant hashtags when sharing links
this will make it easier for people to
find your content when they're searching
for specific topics
remember we talked about owned earned
and paid media social media is no longer
a free game
you now need to pay to play so use paid
advertising on social media platforms
like Facebook you have to promote your
website and specific pages that will
help you in increasing your website
traffic
create content that is easy to share
such as infographic videos and images
people love to share infographics they
are cool they're Innovative yeah and
they are worth sharing so people will
share your content with their own
network thereby driving new website
traffic to your website
once people engage with your content
make sure that you respond to the
comments and the messages on your social
media profiles engage with your
followers because only then will you
build a community around your brand and
encourage more people to visit your
website
and of course obvious make sure that
your calls to action are informative
instructional and entice users to return
to your content Rich website
good
yep so I already mentioned that your
social media on its own isn't enough now
you need to supplement it with paid
advertising paid advertising is a
fantastic way to give your traffic to
your website a boost yeah it's a highly
effective way but it is important to
ensure that your ads are relevant and
well targeted to make sure that you get
the most out of your advertising budget
show pay-per-click advertising yeah
which basically means you pay when
somebody clicks on your ads it allows
you to place ads on search engines so
it's a switch like Google and other
search engines like Bing yeah and also
in other websites where they will be
seen by potential customers who are
searching for products and services when
a user clicks on one of your ads they
will be directed to your website which
can then of course Drive significant
additional traffic to your website and
potentially lead to more conversions
yes so if you compare this with seo seo
takes much longer to achieve as a
valuable source to increase your website
traffic but it's more durable where
pay-per-click advertising is a burst I
can switch on my pay-per-click
advertising that will lead to immediate
traffic to my website immediate
conversions but when I stop my pay
advertising if I run out of budget then
the traffic to the website stops
yes so there is a big difference between
paid and owned uh website traffic now
there are several factors that can
affect the effectiveness of your PPC ads
for driving traffic to your website
first of all it's the relevance of your
ads and the keywords that you're
targeting if your ads are not relevant
they will not be seen by the Right
audience and therefore they may not
drive traffic to your website
second Google will give your ad a
quality score which is a measure of
their relevance and their expected
click-through rates and fringes the
quality of your landing page a higher
quality score will give you a lower cost
for your ad and a better ad placement
okay dare boy more people will see your
ads more people will click on them more
people will visit your website the bid
amount for your bet but that you're
willing to pay for your ad is also very
important
of course if you want to pay more if you
pay more for your ads it gives you
better ad placement but of course it'll
give you higher cost as well
finally the ad copy and the headlines
are important factors for users to click
on the ads so make sure it is clear it's
concise and it's compelling
so overall pay-per-click can be very
effective in driving short-term traffic
to your website by targeting relevant
keywords creating compelling ad copy and
headlines placing ads in relevant
locations and direct visitors to
relevant landing pages
right so that is on the paid advertising
another and they often say one of the
highest one of the marketing instruments
with the highest return on investment of
any marketing channel is email marketing
yeah email marketing their one-to-one
pieces of content with your ideal
customers and you can automate that
process so which can really help in
driving quality website traffic
of course automation has made it simpler
to send out mass emails but it's the
personalization and the audience
segmentation that have made email
marketing so powerful but you can
because you can speak directly to the
concerns of your ideal customers
it can be highly effective to drive
traffic to your website but you need to
play the game properly yeah so here are
a few ways to use email marketing to
achieve this
include links to your website in your
email
yeah conclude links to your website and
specific Pages they say it will allow
you that will allow your subscribers to
easily access your website and the
content that you want to promote
use a clear and compelling call to
action in your email such as learn more
or visit our website so you want to
encourage your subscribers to click
through to your website
very important to personalize your
emails to make them more engaging and
more relevant for your subscribers
optimize your emails for mobile devices
so they're easy to read and easy to
click on and why not use email
automation to send targeted and relevant
messages your to your subscribers based
on their actions or engagement with your
website
you can also use this to segment your
email list based on their demographics
their behaviors and interests so thereby
you can send more targeted and relevant
messages to your specific audience which
will increase the chances of people
clicking to go to your websites
and finally use the email analytics that
you get to track the click-through rate
and the conversion rate of your emails
and adjust your campaigns accordingly
people love to win things yeah so when
you use competitions contests giveaways
it's a guaranteed way to drive and
increase traffic to your website you may
quickly enhance your popularity and show
appreciation to your supporters in doing
this so they could include photos or
video contests a quiz or a survey
contest comments on social media contest
a referral contests sweepstakes puzzle
puzzle or scavenger hunt a caption or a
slogan contest or a poll or a survey
contest
yeah and relevant giveaways they can
include a product giveaway a gift card
or a cash giveaway a membership giveaway
or a subscription giveaway an experience
or a trip giveaway an e-book or a white
paper giveaway or a free demo or a trial
giveaway
yeah so how can you use those contests
here a few tips use your social media
platforms to promote your contests or
giveaways
you shave clear and very compelling call
to action on your website and in your
social media posts such as enter to win
or sign up now
to encourage people to visit your
website and participate and create a
landing page specifically for your
contest and competition and make sure
that landing page is optimized for
conversions with a very clear call to
action and information about a
competition
or for a price that is valuable that is
relevant to your target audience
it said if you're giving away an iPad
you'll it's a waste because you will
just get lots and lots of people who are
there just to win the iPads yeah they
don't care about your product they don't
care about your service it is a waste so
make sure that your price is relevant
and valuable to your Rd audience
share the result of your contest or
giveaway on social media and your
website it makes sure that you're
transparent but also creates a buzz
around your brand use email marketing to
promote your competition or your
giveaway to your subscribers and
encourage people to share your contest
or giveaway with friends and family by
maybe offering a referral program
right so another way of creating website
traffic is by writing guest blog posts
yeah when you guest blog on another
website you can typically include a link
back to your own website
so these are called backlinks they can
help improve your search engine ranking
making it more likely that people will
find the article that you that you wrote
they are particularly on relevant
websites they can give you exposure to
new audiences that may not have found
your website otherwise so it's a great
opportunity for you to Showcase your
expertise your brand and credibility
Yeah by guest blocking on websites that
are relevant to your Niche and Industry
you can attract targeted traffic to your
website so because those are the people
that are likely to be interested in your
product and your service so they are
likely to click thereby driving
um traffic to your your website
yeah make sure that when you Guest block
on other websites that readers can share
your posts on social media that can lead
to even more traffic and of course don't
forget to include a gold call to action
in your guest posts that encourage
readers to sign up for an email list
yeah or you can use guest blocking to
build an email list to drive even more
traffic to your website over time
so it's important to seek out high
quality relevant websites for guest
blogging yep and it graphs high quality
informative and engaging content that is
relevant to the audience of the website
reach out yeah to the guests to the
Publications where you would like to
guest blog and then when you reach out
and give them a good proposition and a
good topic for an article quite often
they will respond positively
an example of a very successful guest
blogging campaign that drove traffic to
the website was from buffer yeah buffer
is a tool that can help you in your
social media outreach they implemented a
guest blogging strategy which helped
them increase their website traffic by
over a hundred thousand visitors in just
two months
it was focused on targeting blogs and
websites that were relevant to their
Niche being social media marketing
they reached out to the website owners
pitching their ideas for guest posts and
offered them high quality informative
content that was relevant to Their
audience
they also included a call to action in
their guest block encouraging readers to
visit their website to learn more about
their social media management tools
yeah so the result of this campaign was
a significant increase in website
traffic and that helped them increase
their brand awareness and credibility in
the markets
we talked about this earlier exchanging
backlinks is a very powerful way to
drive traffic to your website and you
need to make sure that you have a
backlink strategy
yeah so if they can drive traffic to
your website by improving your search
engine ranking which will increase the
chance that people will find your
website when they search for related
keywords
yeah so backlinks are one of the most
important factors that search engines
use to determine the quality and the
relevance of your websites so having a
good backlink strategy is probably one
of the highest priorities in developing
your SEO strategy
they can also Drive referral traffic to
your website when someone clicks on a
link to your website from another
website they're being referred to your
website and that's why it's called a
referral for referral traffic
they can help increase the visibility of
your website yeah it can help expose
your website to new audiences that may
not have found your website otherwise
yeah they help you in brand awareness it
can help expose your brand to new
audiences it can help increase the
number of social media shares that you
receive
yep and a backlink strategy involves
identifying the high quality websites in
your Niche or industry and reach out to
them with a question do you want to
share my piece of content in one of your
articles
yeah and make sure that your content is
high quality and is likely to be shared
infographics is a really good example of
a content type that people really like
to uh to share
yep and there is other stuff that you
can do like Link roundups Link exchanges
and broken link building all in all it
asks for having a good link building
strategy
and finally
don't forget good old PR
earned media coverage refers to the
coverage that your brand or your website
receives from search from third-party
sources like news outlets blogs podcasts
and social media influences they can
drive a tremendous amount of traffic to
your websites by increasing your
visibility and credibility of your brand
and by providing you opportunities and
potential customers to learn more about
your product and service
because when your brand or website is
mentioned in a news article or in a blog
post or a podcast it can help increase
the visibility among the their readers
their listeners and their viewers
so earned media coverage can really help
you in driving traffic to your website
yes so because it also helps you in
establishing trust and credibility so
when your brand is mentioned in a news
article yeah it can expose your brand to
new audiences that otherwise would never
have found you
yep so they include additional
opportunities like having a link to your
website included in the coverage so that
not only drives traffic to your website
but also helps you in your search engine
ranking
so lots of ways to increase your website
traffic and it's finding that right
balance of which tool to use yeah and
which way to increase your activities to
help in driving traffic to your website
make sure that you set your website up
for Google analytics so they track
exactly where your traffic is coming
from they track the growth of your
traffic and they track the
um the the places where people are are
coming from and also other demographic
factors like age gender and what have
you so that's a wrap folks it's a short
introduction to how to grow your traffic
on your your website if you want to know
more about all of this make sure that
you check out all the other simply
learned courses if you like the video
click the like button and if you want to
subscribe to our Channel don't forget to
click on the Subscribe button to join
our existing Learners community on
YouTube that's it from me and I see you
all at the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here